[Music]
jimmy's with us in california hi jimmy
how are you
doing great you did better than i
deserve how can we help
i'm calling because i have a quick
question my wife and i are on baby step
number two
uh we recently just sold our condo made
a profit of around 75 thousand dollars
in the bank right now we have 185. uh
the issue is we have 170 thousand
dollars in student loans
my question is would you save a large
chunk of that we're looking at a home
around six hundred thousand
uh save twenty percent of that for a
down payment or would you pay
place a large sum of that towards the
student loan debt did i understand you
have 185 in the bank 170 in student loan
debt
yes yes you did okay uh well what we
teach folks is don't buy a house until
you're debt free and have an emergency
fund
okay so i think you're renting for a
while because i think you just used 170
of your 185 to become debt free
yeah ow you're not going to do that are
you
well i mean crying he's laughing like
it's the most ludicrous thing he's ever
heard
well you know as ludicrous as it sounds
it also kind of
did just for a second when i said that
did you feel kind of free
yes yes that would be amazing yeah i
mean you have to admit down inside
your stomach that something was set free
when i said that down inside your soul
something was set free
because that 170 looks like it's
insurmountable
it looks like freaking mount everest and
for just a second
i placed you on top of mount everest and
you were cheering for just a second
and then you started rolling your eyes
and going i think this goes crazy
hey jimmy jimmy are you jimmy do you
have a good job
you gainfully employed yeah so i'm an
icu registered nurse and my wife is the
emergency department what's your
household income
uh we are around 160. my god
jimmy here's a fun exercise for you you
and your wife tonight
dinner okay write down what it would
look like what would your financial
situation look like if you paid the 170
off you had 15k
you're living in an rv right yeah and
then you got
really good income what would life look
like i think you just got to get over it
you gotta write it down on paper and
look how fast could you save a hundred
grand
oh my goodness um we paid off to
this was before i knew about your
program yeah we paid off like two
forty thousand dollar cars and like
within a year yeah so i think you can
save a hundred grand a year
and i think you're gonna be in a house
by this time next year
and you're gonna have an emergency fund
and no student loan debt
and you're gonna look back 10 years
later and go that crazy guy on the radio
is right
and if you don't do this you're gonna
limp for a decade
hey you tell people what to do all the
time in your business
and they either do it or they don't this
is the ramsay show